hello and good evening welcome to the
drive home I know that this camera setup
looks like ass but that's because I am
back home in the sense of Natty
why did I say it's stupid like that I'm
back home in Cincinnati but I won't be
home for long because I will be driving
home
very soon anyway it's not a very high
quality camera so I got to go really
dramatic on the lighting because
otherwise if I don't do that
I look like an Oompa Loompa
that is very orange this is the best I
could do with the white balance and so
that's what you get also I would have
done night vision but look at this look
at this look at this stupid thing nope
not that look at this look at this
stupid thing
this stays there
I don't know why
usually that I don't why is this there
it's not like Lexington could take a
patch of my other skin and place that
over that through the whole show
video that would be too much to ask for
no I wouldn't do that I wouldn't do that
whatever it don't matter I'm gonna be
driving home very soon so that's what
I'm playing right it was a Thursday
November 16th I was working late
I drove home
very dramatic very very incredibly
dramatic
is this a blast from the past for
everybody watching at home
is this weird to see me back in this
recording setup if you've been here
since the very beginning
probably
you know usually when I drive home like
this nothing bad ever happens
I don't crash my car I don't go into a
ravine I don't need a Slender Man or a
werewolf or some kind of Cryptid that's
going to crash into my car and cause me
to careen off into Oblivion that never
happens
oh my God oh my God I can see
okay
it's usually an uneventful trip just
like my trip back home will be to LA
from Cincinnati
probably
something's supposed to be happening
it's real dark on the outsides of this
I mean it's night time so I guess that's
pretty bad like no one question that I I
do know that night is dark I do get that
but it's particularly dark so
oh
I don't know if they got gas out oh
that's weird
usually running low on gas doesn't cause
your lights to flicker like that
oh
oh that's okay it just ran out of gas I
knew that was gonna happen
well good thing I didn't pull off to the
side or nothing
I guess I'm done
that's what I get for not getting gas
flashlight
well I tried using my phone but I didn't
get any signal uh
sure about that
okay
whatever you say I decided to follow the
road until I find a gas station or
something okay yeah that's what I do
definitely what I do
oh yeah shift is go slower
that seems right
that's not weird
um
hello sign what nightmares do you hold
for me
what does that mean
boobs ahead I don't I've never seen any
is it bumps
bumps
and bumps a bumps ahead
this is a bumpy place
is there a weird black dot on the moon
is it an eyeball
strange oh hello hi can you help me
ah good I saw a house I decided to go
there and ask for help I'm sure this is
gonna go great for me
always do
hello
it's me
open the door
open the door fine
I should go break into their car
let me in
FIFA foam and whatnot
I'm peeking in your windows
I'm looking at all your stuff
oh I saw a back door which was open
really weird
yeah definitely I'm going in I'm going
in everybody oh whoa hello thought I
could maybe find a telephone to call for
help in their bathroom
let me just take a big dump in their
toilet they won't mind
weird goblet
hmm
[Music]
uh-huh hello
awesome
not good unfortunately it didn't work
was my closet always
open like that
those really are the nightmare closets I
don't know why they're there what did I
I missed the message what was I supposed
to do I didn't see it
uh-huh
hello was I supposed to leave
immediately was there an urgent crisis
with which I
need to leave
hello
hello
Roger's locked I needed to find a key
uh-huh
ah
yep
uh-huh
where would a key be
uh-huh
okay
not here
anybody seen a key
anybody key for me
key
that was me nobody panic I did that
all by myself
huh
where would a key be
in here
I don't see one
well frick
oh there it is I see it and why it's
here I have no idea I found the key
key for me
this is definitely going to do me good
why what happened oh that that I didn't
see that because
my path my heart sank or something oh
man I shouldn't be stepping all in here
hey guys can
well that's all I needed I'm out of here
everybody milk oh all right see you
around guys he'll go out the front nope
why would I do that that would be the
quickest way out
[Music]
I'm running I'm running I'm running now
her running in my car like a madman
I'm not even gonna bother with me I'm
running like a perfectly ordinary person
I swear it felt like something was
following me
interesting ideas you have what a vivid
imagination
once I get to the safety of my car I'll
refuel it then drive away you were
speaking in the past tense for a while
there
and then you started I have a phone call
ringing on me
my mom which is weird because I'm at my
mom's house
okay one second mom I'm about to be free
and go home all safe like
definitely
so goopy I refueled it I can drive away
now definitely not something waiting for
me in my car
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm fine
definitely fine
we are so good
well
crisis averted everybody
crisis averted
[Music]
[Music]
nice suit that's a that's a nice suit
oh pretty good I knew it was going to be
in the car but I'm glad that they didn't
have it there right away so that I turn
around because the instinct is to check
your back seat right I like that I like
that a lot I do enjoy that
and just as abruptly uh here ends this
video
[Music]
thank you